im moment geht es bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen noch vor allem
um inhalte aber schon bald wird es um
posten gehen und da habe ich eine ganz
besondere anforderung an die zukünftigen
ministerinnen und minister ich fordere
eine eltern quote für die nächste
regierung und das vor allem aus zwei
gründen zum einen glaube ich dass viele
fehler die in der kommunalpolitik
begangen wurden nicht gemacht worden
wären wenn merkel sparen scholz altmann
wenn sie kinder gehabt hätten es gab so
viele sensationelle verrückte regelung
bei denen sich viele väter und mütter
gefragt haben hat die spitze des staates
überhaupt noch ein bezug zur realität
wir leben ja zum glück in einer
gesellschaft in der auf vielfalt und
diversität eine große rolle gelegt wird
wir haben für alles quotenfrauen roten
aufsichtsrat milchquoten warum also
nicht auch eine eltern quote deutschland
ist schon jetzt das kinderärmste land
europas die zahlen sind in den letzten
jahren immer weiter zurückgegangen und
ich fürchte dass dieser trend sich
weiter verschärfen wird wenn wir nicht
endlich die familien mehr in den fokus
rücken ich frage mich ob die familien
noch zu einer größe und so noch zu einer
kleinen minderheit zusammenschrumpfen
müssen bis man sie endlich schützt warum
ich noch für eine quote 7 der zweite
grund ist wer eine familie hat der lernt
haushaltsführung arbeitsteilung der
lernt effektiv zu sein der lernt
zuzuhören der lernt in demut und vor
allem lernt er verantwortung für sein
eigenes wieder
zurück auch mal wenn man fehler gemacht
und verantwortung für sein handeln und
das ist etwas was ich bei politikern im
moment tatsächlich vermisse und ich
glaube wer kinder hat die müssen noch
mehr daran gelegen für eine lebenswerte
zukunft zu kämpfen
kurzum eltern sind die besseren
politiker ich finde das einen sehr guten
vorschlag wir haben ja lange genug
erlebt dass es debatten über die
kinderrechte im grundgesetz gehabt das
ist ja voll beschriebenes papier und
nützt überhaupt nix ist ja auch nicht
zustande gekommen weil es zu ochs chris
da sage jetzt keiner noch eine quote die
das ist ja
das können sich die parteien selbst
setzen dieses ziel die spd setzt sich
hat zum ziel dass die hälfte ihrer
minister frauen sind und genauso gut
kann sie sagen für sich selber und die
hälfte mindestens unser minister hat
kinder oder ein kind ist elternteil kann
man sagen steht jedem frei und das finde
ich sehr wichtig weil das geht doch
sozusagen über das frau sein hinaus da
hat man noch eine ganz andere
lebenserfahrung und ganz andere aufgaben
und man ist ich bin ja selbst vater von
zwei töchtern
die sind schon über 30
mandat wird das leben erst rund mit
kindern wird das leben rund vorher hat
man nicht richtig gelebt hat man
vielleicht auf regen gelebt und
aber erfüllt lebt man erst mit kindern
ab und solche leute möchten die
regierungen haben aber was ist also man
muss jetzt ich bin total gegen quoten
also dementsprechend es wäre für mich
fürchterlich wenn das passiere nicht
zusätzlich will ich auch immer also ich
würde niemals in den gesetzlichen quote
dafür wollen vor allem weil ich auch
immer glaube man darf auch nicht
vergessen es gibt auch viele frauen in
deutschland die uns einfach auch nicht
vergönnt ist kindern kommen natürlich
ganz schweres schicksal und wenn man
jetzt noch so quoten einfährt ist ja
wirklich so jetzt müssen wir uns noch
mal zeigen ebenso gott du kannst es ja
nicht wie schlecht du du bist nicht rund
das leben fängt nicht an denn deswegen
das sind die zwei punkte was immer noch
ergänzen wir haben jetzt sich aber
eigentlich an die bombe ist angela
merkel hat ja keine kinder olaf scholz
hat ja schon in seinen 20ern wenn ich es
richtig gelesen habe es gab ein porträt
in dem spiegel da schien es mir so als
hätte er das als entscheidung getroffen
keine kinder zu bekommen und sich ganz
der arbeit widmen genauso wie seine frau
das auch neben der politik nicht genug
platz für ein kind wäre muss man da
nicht eher sagen die den deutschen ist
es egal weil ich meine sie hat schon
wieder jemand ohne kein kind gewählt das
weiß ich nicht aber es geht ja nicht
darum dass wir jemanden wählen ich habe
ja nicht scholz gewählt ich denke der
hat keine kinder sondern ich möchte dass
die minister sich so zusammensetzen das
zumindest welchen mit schulpflichtigen
kindern dabei muss dann musst du mit uns
übrigens früher hatten
hatten die regierungschefs deutschland
sehr viele kinder dass schröder hatte
dann schon keine mehr also adaptiert
adoptiert und die letzten wann wenn
nicht jetzt dann haben wir schon heute
kinder jaja jesinger weiß ich nicht
adenauer hatte auch sehr viele der hat
er ganz allein wir können ja auch den
schönen satz alle unsere kinder sollen
es mal besser haben als wir wenn das
sozusagen richtschnur des politischen
handelns wäre in unserem land das wäre
wahrscheinlich gut ich bin aber trotzdem
gegen quoten tatsächlich weiß du sagst
du selbst gesagt immer noch eine quote
migrantenquote diese quote dass die
parteien sollen gern leute aufstehen
wenn
nicht für eltern und ich meine frau
rothe die parteien für sich ob sich an
kunden die parteien
in deutschland das ist dass es nicht
wenig aber wie gesagt es wird immer
weniger und ich sehe das problem es war
unfassbar was im letzten jahr
von kindern verlangt wurde was von
eltern verlangen würde es gab es gab
regelung wohl meine freundin wo andere
väter wo wir gedacht haben haben sie das
jetzt wirklich so entschieden wenn also
ich habe meinen mann wir arbeiten beide
vollzeit wir sollten aber unseren sohn
ich habe zwei kinder fünf und neun also
eine in der kita die wir dann
geschlossen mein sohn 9 hatte
homeschooling wochen lang wie sollen
wenn zwei eltern arbeiten und nicht
jeder war in kurzarbeit und nicht jeder
kann hunger also ich bin reporterin ich
musste draußen rum rein und das mache
ich ja auch gerne aber wie soll man
gleichzeitig aufs kind aufpassen fünf
stunden unterrichten mindestens acht
stunden arbeitet mein mann hat teilweise
abends um 23 uhr angefangen zu arbeiten
ja weil wir das gar nicht anders
abdecken konnten das gegenüber monate
und monat bei markmonitor hatten kinder
und es war der strikteste start bayern
er hat kann also markus söder weil es
für mich total das gegenargument dass es
nicht besser gewesen wäre wenn die
kinder gehabt hätten weil markus söder
zum beispiel kann nicht mein freund von
mir also mit nicht er aber dadurch den
hintergrund oder ich glaube du hast er
auf million gefahr gekommen kinder
selbst betreuen also um gymnasium ja
aber dann musst du dich nicht mehr die
ganze zeit kümmern wollen gute für
kleinere kinder haben also sachen 16
jähriges kind muss man online seine
schwester wieder auge nicht mehr sehen
das heißt meine eltern hätten jetzt gar
keine quote mehr erfüllt mit mir mit 29
meiner schwester mit reiner braun online
quote unter 3 jährige ja was sagen sie
dazu hätte wurde schon bei unter 10 ich
möchte jetzt mal von den von den kinder
manchmal so heißt weil er sicher dass es
im bereich ich würde mir wünschen dass
wir ministerinnen und minister haben die
mal wieder ahnung vom fach haben genau
wie wir argumentieren und sagen die
sollten kinder
naja da würde ich mir wünschen dass die
innenpolitiker juristisches fachwissen
mitbringen oder im günstigsten fall
sogar noch polizist das haben sie ja
alle die von der von der straße
abgekommen ja polizei und noch viel mehr
verteidigungsministerium ja wenn da mal
wieder einer säße den teil der aussieht
weiß wie ein soldat aussieht und was er
macht entschuldigen aber ich persönlich
denke er auch dass ein
verteidigungsminister beim bund gewesen
sein sollte aber
nicht so
aber sie hat es gerade habe ich
bin aber die hand will ich nicht dafür
ins feuer legen ich glaube er war nicht
bei der bundeswehr verteidigungsminister
das galt damals auch als
als fortschrittlich weil da kommt einer
reihen der war ja auch kein schlechter
verteidigungsminister das muss nichts
heißen aber auch da haben nur von jemand
operiert werden der es gelernt hat ich
finde auch justin turbo zb in kanada der
das wesentlich besser gemacht das system
da haben die minister wirklich alle
ahnung die wurden genauso besetzt als
natürlich der verteidigungsminister
jemand der sehr hoch gedient hat ich
finde das intro duster definitiv ein
vorbild wenn man einen blick und da bin
ich auch bei diego und gegen die quote
aber da haben nicht bei dir ich finde
wenn soldat die müssen ja dienen und
beim soldaten ist eine krasse hierarchie
bis nach oben und plötzlich kommen die
höchste schätzung war noch nie bei der
bundeswehr annegret kramp karrenbauer
hat nicht gedient ursula von der leyen
hat nicht gedient für mich weil es auch
völlig vermessen frau wird die abwehr
war aber es gibt aussicht darauf dass es
jetzt ein gibt ja da war lars klingbeil
spd generalsekretär stammt sogar aus
einer soldaten familie und er war im
verteidigungsausschuss hat ist also ein
doppelter hinsicht
haben wir einen tisch und vergeben wir
haben schlecht oder das war ziemlich
wurscht ob der spd kommt oder sonst
woher der versteht einfach was davon und
das in das haben die soldaten auch
verdient genauso wie die polizei
verdient hat das dann innenminister
sitzt der der nicht mehr an bayern denkt
und an seine karriere an der csu
[Musik]